que les autres poissons qu'ils ont vus avant.
Je pense les humains font à peu près pareil inconsciemment.
On se laisse le temps de tâter le terrain,
de comprendre le marché quand on est jeune.
Ce n'est qu'alors qu'on commence à chercher sérieusement,
vers le milieu ou la fin de la vingtaine.
Je pense que c'est la preuve, s'il en fallait une,
que tous les cerveaux sont préconfigurés pour être un peu mathématiques.
Donc c'était l'astuce n°2.
Maintenant, l'astuce n°3 : comment éviter le divorce.
Imaginons que vous ayez trouvé le partenaire idéal
et que vous entriez dans une relation à vie avec lui.
J'aime à penser que tout le monde aimerait éviter le divorce,
à part peut-être la femme de Piers Morgan.
C'est une triste réalité de la vie moderne
qu'un mariage sur deux aux États-Unis se termine par un divorce,
avec le reste du monde pas loin derrière.
On vous excusera de penser peut-être
que les disputes qui précèdent une rupture conjugale
ne sont pas dignes d'une étude mathématique.
Il est vrai que c'est dur de savoir
ce qu'il faut mesurer ou ce qu'il faut quantifier.
Mais ça n'a pas empêché le psychologue John Gottman de le faire.
Gottman a observé des centaines de couples qui discutaient
et il a enregistré tout ce que vous pouvez imaginer.
Il a enregistré ce qui se disait dans la conversation,
il a enregistré la conductivité cutanée,
il a enregistré les expressions du visage,
le rythme cardiaque, la pression artérielle,
presque tout sauf si la femme avait toujours raison,
ce qui se trouve être le cas.
Ce que Gottman et son équipe ont trouvé,
c'est qu'un des indicateurs importants
d'un éventuel divorce du couple
était à quel point chacun était positif ou négatif pendant la conversation.
Les couples à faible profil de risque
avaient plus de points positifs que négatifs sur l'échelle de Gottman.
Alors que les mauvaises relations,
susceptibles de finir en divorce,
se trouvaient dans une spirale de négativité.
En utilisant ces idées très simples,
Gottman et son équipe ont pu prédire
si un couple allait ou non divorcer
avec une précision de 90%.
Mais c'est quand il s'est associé avec le mathématicien James Murray
qu'il a vraiment commencé à comprendre
ce qui provoquait ces spirales de négativité et comment elles survenaient.
Toutes leurs conclusions
sont à mon sens incroyablement simples et intéressantes.
Ces équations prédisent comment l'homme ou la femme va répondre
dans leur prochain tour de conversation,
à quel point ils vont être positifs ou négatifs.
Ces équations dépendent de
l'humeur de la personne quand elle est seule,
de son humeur quand elle est avec son partenaire,
et surtout, elles dépendent de
combien mari et femme s'influencent.
Je pense qu'il est important de faire ressortir à ce stade
que ces mêmes équations se sont montrées
parfaitement aptes à décrire
ce qui ce passe entre deux pays dans une course à l'armement.
(Rires)
Donc -- un couple qui se chamaille, dans une spirale de négativité
et au bord du divorce --
est mathématiquement équivalent à un début de guerre nucléaire.
(Rires)
Mais le terme le plus important de cette équation
est l'influence que les gens ont les uns sur les autres
et en particulier, quelque chose appelé le seuil de négativité.
Donc, pour le seuil de négativité,
imaginez à quel point le mari doit être agaçant
avant que la femme ne commence à s'énerver, et vice versa.
Pour moi, les bons mariages étaient faits de compromis et de compréhension
et laissaient assez de place à chaque personne pour être elle-même.
J'aurais donc pensé que peut-être les relations les plus réussies
étaient celles où le seuil de négativité était le plus élevé.
Où les couples laissaient passer
et n'abordaient les choses que si c'était très important.
Mais en fait, les mathématiques et les résultats de la recherche
ont démontré que c'est le contraire qui est vrai.
Les meilleurs couples ou les couples à succès
sont ceux avec des seuils de négativité très bas.
Ce sont des couples qui ne laissent rien passer
et se donnent assez d'espace pour se plaindre.
Ce sont les couples qui essaient constamment de réparer leur relation,
qui ont une perspective plus positive de leur union.
Les couples qui ne laissent pas aller
les choses et qui ne laissent pas grossir les choses triviales réussissent le mieux.
Bien sûr, il faut plus qu'un faible seuil de négativité
et une absence de compromis pour faire un mariage à succès.
Mais je pense qu'il est intéressant
de savoir qu'il y a des preuves mathématiques
comme quoi il ne faut pas laisser une dispute inachevée.
Donc voilà mes trois astuces
sur comment les maths peuvent vous aider avec l'amour.
J'espère qu'à part leur utilité comme astuces,
qu'elles vous donnent un aperçu de la puissance des maths.
Car pour moi, les équations et symboles ne sont pas juste des choses.
Ce sont des voix qui disent l'incroyable richesse de la nature
et l'étonnante simplicité
des modèles qui s'emmêlent et évoluent autour de nous,
du fonctionnement du monde à notre comportement.
J'espère que, pour quelques-uns d'entre vous,
ce petit aperçu des mathématiques de l'amour
vous persuadera d'avoir un peu plus d'amour pour les maths.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)